es gibt zu viele situationen wo man
denken die patienten entwickeln sich zu
positiv so ich muss ihn einmal die zähne
dann kommt man nach zwei tagen wieder
und dem patienten geht so viel
schlechter als am anfang
hallo
man fragt sich habe ich jetzt was falsch
gemacht habe ich was übersehen gehen
auch sich die nase und man auch wenn sie
zum beispiel auch sagen okay war
vielleicht doch nicht so geschickt dass
ich mich nicht impfen lassen das ist ein
moment wo ich dann denkt okay gut jetzt
kapiert
[Musik]
ich arbeite seit fast vier jahren auf
der gascogne tensid momentan ist sie mir
eine corona intensivstation wir haben
aktuell 20 betten für patienten die sind
auch voll belegt hier werden die
besonders schweren verläufe behandelt
alle patienten müssen beatmet werden
[Musik]
dorin david ward hat das schlimmste
überstanden
er ist 51 jahre alt ungeimpft wie die
meisten cupid patienten hier
[Musik]
war als lkw-fahrer in ganz europa
unterwegs auf einer der touren hat er
sich angesteckt
wenn seine blutwerte in ordnung sind
kann dorin david watt heute auf die
normalstation verlegt werden
noch vor 14 tagen hätte damit niemand
gerechnet
er wurde eine nacht lang versucht
mittels der high flow sauerstoff gabe
und spontaner auflage vor der innovation
zu bewahren das hat leider nicht
funktioniert und er zeigt einmal auf die
lunge er musste am frühen morgen dann
auch intubiert werden und lagen
letztendlich zehn tage intubiert und
beatmet im koma
und dann kann man sagen einmal
[Musik]
ok mit dort komplett
naja war
komplett schwarz
dann kommt halt nicht
wo kann man sich noch so kommt er sagte
zu mir du musst dir was
erfahrungen im grenzbereich für
patienten aber auch die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter der klinik während
draußen die infektionszahlen explodieren
arbeitet eva lange oft am rande ihrer
belastungsgrenze natürlich es ist immer
wieder beruhigend jetzt gerade in der
aktuellen situation wenig halt alles
entwickelt und manchmal hatte ich auch
momente wo ich mir dann die frage
stellen wo soll das alles hinführen was
also wie geht's weiter und das ist in
zwei jahren wird das jetzt für ewig so
weitergehen viele der schweren
schicksale auf evas station wären durch
eine co wird impfung vermeidbar einer
ihrer patienten wird seit eineinhalb
monaten künstlich beatmet er bekommt
starke schmerz und schlafmittel
sein zustand hat sich nicht verbessert
auch er anfang 50 ungeimpft kam schon
intubiert aus einem kleineren haus
hierher die uni klinik heidelberg als
letzte chance können sie mal versuchen
meine hand zu drücken
weil die anderen seite versuchen man
muss sagen er hat seine kurve zu
erkrankungen jetzt also er hat seine
erkrankungen sagen nur überlebt den
schwersten
das sag ich mal so die akutphase
und es hier eben jetzt als langzeit
beatmete prozent bei uns auf station eva
hat ihn nie wach erlebt den mann hinter
dem schlauch kennt sie nicht
er hat weiterhin sedierung laufen das
ist sehr schwierig mit ihm zu
kommunizieren beziehungsweise seine
neurologie einzuschätzen
er hat die augen zwar offen aber bei
ansprache reagiert er sehr schlecht also
eigentlich gar nicht kommt kein
aufforderung nach und
das ist auch immer so ein nicht so gutes
zeichen wenn die patienten nach so
langer zeit auch einfach nicht wach
werden
[Musik]
wenn sie mal versuchen mich anzuschauen
zu meiner stimme zu gehen mit den augen
wieder keine reaktion auch alle versuche
die beatmung runterzufahren sind bislang
gescheitert
[Musik]
ich glaube jeder denkt dass jeder weiß
dass jeder hat das bauchgefühl dass das
nicht gut aussieht aber solange sich
nichts zum schlechteren verändert können
wir auch nicht handeln
ich stehe jetzt mal hier auf der anderen
seite
können sie mich mal anschauen wir geben
ihm alle antibiotika die sein team
entsprechend die wir im körper gefunden
haben wir versorgen ihnen wir waschen
den wir bieten ihnen eine gucken dass
der magen darm trakt funktioniert wir
geben ihm ernährung aber insofern steht
das alles still
je länger der zustand andauert desto
größer ist das risiko für komplikationen
die maschinelle beatmung schädigt die
lunge mit der zeit zusätzlich
die chancen auf eine genesung schwinden
immer weiter
viele patienten mit 50 haben keine
patientenverfügung oder jeweils
festgelegt dass ich jemals gedanken
darüber gemacht was denn passiert wenn
sie jemals im koma beatmet auf eine
intensivstation danken
die angehörigen müssen oft schwierige
entscheidungen treffen
[Musik]
die angehörigen haben das letzte wort
und den ausnahmefällen besteht dann auch
die möglichkeit dass die angehörigen
auch hierher kommen und sich vielleicht
auch ein bild davon machen wieder
bisschen aussieht und dass der patient
eigentlich gar nicht wenn so aussieht
wie der mensch den sie zu hause kannten
ich verabschiede mich von ihnen
und schon bald mal wieder nach ihm alles
gute tschüss
[Musik]
du rhin david ward geht es besser ob er
sich jetzt impfen lässt weiß er
allerdings noch nicht
[Musik]
normalerweise über
der gähn
des tages gesehen ich gut
und wichtig für verwirrung
ich wurde
nicht gesehen
eva bleibt geduldig wo anderen in ihrer
situation wohl die worte weg bleiben
würden
[Musik]
auf jeden fall auch sagen also cds
geschäften 80 bis 85 prozent nächste
ja
also ich will ja nichts in den mund
legen oder so dass es ihre eigene stadt
schlägt ist eine farbige server 50 50
die dann trotz schwerem verlauf auf
intensivstationen beatmet aufwachen und
sagen na ja irgendwie sehe ich trotzdem
nicht so wirklich dem effekt auf das ist
dann schon schade weil wir ja jetzt auch
gesehen haben im letzten jahr das ist
wirklich effektiv ist und der ja
wirklich eigentlich die letzten monate
gerade während der vierten welle
hauptsächlich umkämpfte patientendaten
und ist immer weitergeht
die vierte welle in der pandemie für
menschen wie eva langer ist ein ende der
außergewöhnlichen belastungen überhaupt
nicht absehbar
[Musik]